[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es ein leckeres Kuchenrezept.
Eigentlich wollte ich gerade was anderes filmen,
aber dann habe ich Erdbeeren und Rhabarber
in meinem Kühlschrank entdeckt
und ich dachte mir,
ich mache einen Streuselkuchen.
Also machen wir jetzt einen Blechkuchen
mit Erdbeeren und Rhabarber.
Ich werde dazu einen Quark-Öl-Teig machen,
mache Streusel noch dazu.
Und im Prinzip sind es dann vier Komponenten,
einmal die Streusel, der Quark-Öl-Teig,
die fruchtige Füllung
und dann noch so was Ähnliches wie Pudding,
aber aus Quark.
Es sieht jetzt aus, als wären es viele Zutaten.
Aber am Ende sind es gar nicht so viele.
Also ich hatte bei mir alles im Vorrat.
Erdbeeren und Rhabarber
müsst ihr vielleicht noch dazukaufen.
Aber die sind ja momentan in der Saison.
Starten tun wir jetzt
– tun wir –
mit den Streuseln.
Ich nehme dafür 250 Gramm Mehl,
125 Gramm kalte Butter,
125 Gramm Zucker,
eine Prise Salz und Vanilleextrakt.
Und hier habe ich auch schon mal die Fruchtfüllung gerichtet.
Dafür nehme ich nämlich Rhabarber,
Erdbeeren,
etwas Stärke
und auch Vanilleextrakt.
Für die Streusel gebe ich einfach
alle Zutaten in eine Schüssel.
Die könnt ihr entweder mit einem Mixer zubereiten
oder mit den Händen
oder mit einem Handrührgerät.
Also Salz noch rein und Zucker
und Vanille.
[Musik]
Ich liebe einfach Streusel!
Ich nehme jetzt hier so einen Teigzerhacker.
Damit kann man die Butter nämlich schön zerhacken.
Und jetzt einfach verbinden,
bis sich die Streusel gebildet haben.
Gleich nehme ich noch die Hände dazu.
Aber am Anfang passt es so ganz gut.
Denn dann kann ich die Butter so ein bisschen zerkleinern
und dann habe ich es gleich ein bisschen einfacher.
Wenn die Butter dann klein genug ist,
nehme ich einfach die Hände dazu.
[Musik]
Nein.
Jetzt wartest du auf den fertigen Kuchen.
Aber, Samira, ich kann dir gleich mal was geben.
Kannst du die Schüssel kaltstellen?
Ich mache es lieber selber.
Sonst landet sie in Samiras Bauch.
>> SAMIRA: Lass mich mal gucken.
Ich bin eh gleich weg.
>> SALLY: Ah!
Habe ich gesehen!
[Musik]
Jetzt kann ich die Fruchtfüllung zubereiten.
Die Erdbeeren könnt ihr entweder vierteln, achteln,
in Würfel schneiden oder in Scheiben.
Ich glaube, ich schneide sie in Scheiben.
[Musik]
Guck mal, Samira.
Hier kannst du weitermachen,
kannst du schöne Scheiben schneiden,
ohne dich zu schneiden.
>> SAMIRA: Ups.
>> SALLY: Ja, einfach mehr Druck.
>> SAMIRA: Ich muss mehr Schwung nehmen, oder was?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Und einfach durchdrücken.
Und ich kann schon mal den Rhabarber schälen.
Und, wenn es zu voll wird,
genau, und jetzt hier drauf.
Warte.
Genau. Einfach darauf absetzen und zack.
Kannst du das auch, Rhabarber schälen?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Warte. Ich komme noch.
Guck mal. Einfach so.
Und oben nicht so viel wegschneiden.
Also man schneidet eigentlich nur ein bisschen,
damit man so die Fäden abziehen kann.
>> SAMIRA: Hä?
Also ich habe noch nie einen Rhabarber geschnitten,
aber schon...
>> SALLY: Warte. Von der anderen Seite.
Andere Seite.
Guck.
Guck mal. Guck mal bei mir.
Ich setze das Messer an
und dann ziehe ich es einfach nur ab.
Und jetzt abziehen.
Nee, nee, nee.
Guck mal.
Guck mal her.
Hier ansetzen.
Und jetzt ziehst du das so hoch
und du häutest es praktisch nur.
>> SAMIRA: Ah.
>> SALLY: Du musst nicht mit dem Messer komplett durch.
Also theoretisch geht es auch,
genau, mit einem stumpfen Messer oben.
Man muss nur einmal unter die Schale kommen
sozusagen.
[Musik]
Jetzt den Rhabarber einfach noch fein schneiden.
Und das geschälte Gewicht sind jetzt hier 750 Gramm.
750 Gramm auch Erdbeeren,
also einfach eins zu eins.
Wenn ihr das Ganze jetzt ohne Erdbeeren macht,
sondern nur Rhabarber verwendet,
würde ich auf den Fall ein bisschen Zucker dazu geben.
Aber hier bekomme ich ja jetzt die Süße durch die Erdbeeren.
Jetzt kommt gleich mein Standardspruch, Josh.
>> JOSH: Eine größere Schüssel, oder?
>> SALLY: Man kann auch
eine etwas größere Schüssel nehmen.
Was wunderbar zu Erdbeeren und Rhabarber passt,
ist Vanille.
Also entweder ein bisschen Vanillezucker oder Vanilleextrakt.
Aber Vanilleextrakt ist halt
viel, viel intensiver,
weil es nämlich echte Vanille ist.
So.
Dann noch die Stärke zum Binden.
Die nehme ich jetzt wegen der Erdbeere,
weil die Erdbeere einfach viel Feuchtigkeit enthält.
Ich glaube, ich rühre das jetzt kurz so.
Denn
mit einem Teigschaber
wird das schwierig.
Nehmt eine größere Schüssel!
Ich mache einfach in Zeitlupe.
>> JOSH: Ist gut. Brauchen wir gar keine Slowmo-Bilder.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Hier, ich mache dir eine Echtzeit-Slowmo.
Och, wie das riecht!
O mein Gott!
Ich könnte das jetzt gerade löffeln.
Würde ich aber nicht tun, weil der Rhabarber roh ist.
Und jetzt
lasse ich die Masse hier kurz stehen
und kann noch die zwei übrigen Komponenten zubereiten,
zum einen die Quarkcreme für zum Draufklecksen
wie so eine Art Pudding
und zum anderen den Quark-Öl-Teig.
Für die Quarkcreme nehme ich
250 Gramm Quark,
ein Ei,
30 Gramm Zucker,
25 Gramm Stärke
und etwas Vanilleextrakt.
Und jetzt könnt ihr hier einfach alle Zutaten vermischen
in einer Schüssel, die groß genug ist.
Werden wir gleich sehen.
[Musik]
Immer, wenn ich jetzt den Löffel nicht so ablege,
muss ich an den Sturmi denken,
weil der immer die Löffelablage so hypt.
Hier Zucker und Stärke zum Binden.
Und Vanille.
In den Teig kommt keine Vanille.
Da kommt was anderes.
Ja.
Nein, auch kein Tonka.
Und jetzt verrühren.
Ja, Samira, ich mache ein Feuer.
Tschu!
Fertig.
Perfekt!
Komponente drei ist fertig.
Und jetzt kommt der Teig.
Den macht man nämlich zum Schluss,
da da Backpulver enthalten ist.
Und, sobald der Teig nämlich gleich gemacht ist,
geht es schon auf das Blech.
Für den Teig nehme ich
250 Gramm Quark,
zwei Eier,
200 Gramm Milch,
70 Gramm Öl,
500 Gramm Mehl,
zwei Teelöffel Backpulver,
125 Gramm Zucker,
etwas Salz
und Zitronenabrieb.
Und ein Quark-Öl-Teig ist wirklich superschnell gemacht!
Ich habe jetzt auch den Ofen schon vorgeheizt.
Der sollte jetzt auch schon bereit sein.
Ich nehme jetzt erst mal hier die flüssigen
oder halt, ja, feuchten Zutaten.
Quark.
Und immer, wenn ich Quark auf meinem Blog
oder in der App stehen habe, nehme ich immer Magerquark.
Und, wenn ich einen anderen Quark nehme,
Sahnequark zum Beispiel,
dann schreibe ich es dazu.
Dann die Eier.
Milch.
Und jetzt kann ich die Zutaten schon mal ganz kurz verrühren.
Beim Quark-Öl-Teig
kann man eigentlich nichts falsch machen.
Außer, man kann zu lange rühren.
Aber der ist wirklich superschnell.
Also, wenn es ganz, ganz schnell mal gehen muss
und ihr keine Lust oder keine Zeit auf Rührölteig
oder auf Rührteig, Biskuit oder andere Teige habt,
könnt ihr den immer super zubereiten.
Denn man muss wirklich nur
die flüssigen Zutaten erst verrühren
und dann die trockenen dazu
und fertig.
Also hier Mehl und Backpulver.
Zucker, Salz und Zitrone.
Und jetzt nur kurz verrühren, bis sich alles verbunden hat.
[Musik]
Perfekt!
Guckt mal.
Das ist so ein 60-Sekunden-Teig.
Und jetzt habe ich hier schon mein Backblech.
Das stelle ich jetzt auf 25 mal 30 cm ein.
Ihr könnt, wenn ihr jetzt die Größe nicht habt
oder kleiner oder größer backen wollt,
zum Beispiel ein ganzes Blech,
ganz einfach in meiner App alles umrechnen lassen.
Gebt die Backformgröße ein.
Ihr könnt auch einen runden Kuchen backen
und zum Beispiel 20 cm im Durchmesser eingeben.
Und dann rechnen sich die Zutaten
automatisch in der App um.
Also ihr müsst nicht unbedingt diese Größe nehmen.
[Musik]
Und da kommt jetzt zuerst der Teig rein.
Wenn er nicht ganz so schön geschmeidig ist,
einfach noch ein bisschen Milch dazu geben.
Aber bei mir passt das jetzt so.
Der soll jetzt auch nicht so flüssig sein.
[Musik]
Wenn ihr ihn etwas flacher haben wollt,
dann könnt ihr den Backrahmen einfach größer einstellen.
Das wird jetzt schon so ein höherer Kuchen.
Aber ich glaube,
ich finde es gut.
Ich mache jetzt doch 30 mal 30 cm.
Denn der geht immer megagut auf.
Das wäre dann der Schwabentrick,
einfach größer gemacht.
Der Murat wäre stolz auf mich!
Dann könnt ihr hier jetzt die Quarkcreme darüber träufeln,
einfach so darüber klecksen.
Dazwischen dann die Früchte.
Und die Streusel obendrauf.
[Musik]
Ich habe jetzt doch nicht alle Früchte genommen.
Ich schreibe euch auf jeden Fall
die geänderte Menge in die App.
Denn es sind ein paar zu viel.
Aber die koche ich gleich ein.
Dann habe ich noch wie so eine Art Kompott.
Aber mit ein bisschen Zucker.
Jetzt noch die Streusel drauf.
Und dann darf der Kuchen in den Backofen.
[Musik]
Der Kuchen ist jetzt gebacken.
Er hat tatsächlich länger als eine Stunde backen müssen.
Denn es ist ja auch viel Masse.
Jetzt haben wir ihn abkühlen lassen.
Und jetzt löse ich ihn hier kurz raus.
Kevin bringt den Müll weg.
Hast du ihn gesehen?
Achtung. Er läuft gleich wieder zurück.
>> SAMIRA: Hallo, Kevin!
Da ist er!
>> SALLY: Wisst ihr was? Ich schneide euch Mädels...
>> SAMIRA: Glitzer! Ich will! Ich will Glitzer machen!
>> SALLY: Yay, Glitzer-Schnee!
Nicht zu viel! Okay?
Nicht zu viel Glitzer-Schnee.
Aber ein bisschen was.
Muss natürlich sein.
Oh, warte. Ich mache die große Öffnung.
Mach so, dass man so ein bisschen...
>> SAMIRA: Warte.
[Musik]
Warte.
>> SAMIRA: Mann, der glitzert nicht so...
>> SALLY: Hier die Ecke noch ein bisschen.
Perfekt!
Komm, dann kann ich schon mal
ein Stück für euch anschneiden.
Dann dürft ihr zwei probieren.
>> GRETA: Du hattest schon eine ganz glitzernde Hand.
>> SALLY: Drei Mädels im Video.
Hier.
Ihr dürft probieren.
>> SAMIRA: Okay.
Hast du das?
>> GRETA: Ja. Du hast Glitzer geregnet.
>> SALLY: Da.
Dann probiere ich.
>> SAMIRA: Ich wusste es.
>> SALLY: Also ich finde ihn lecker.
Du, Greta?
>> GRETA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> SAMIRA: Das ist nur so witzig.
>> SALLY: Vor allem passen die Streusel gut
zu der süß-säuerlichen Erdbeere mit dem Rhabarber, gell?
Und er ist nicht zu süß.
Deswegen kann man ruhig noch ein bisschen
Glitzerschnee darauf machen.
Oder Puderzucker.
Also probiert den Kuchen gerne aus.
Die Mädels, die kichern jetzt hier noch vor sich hin.
Und das Rezept gibt es wie immer in meiner App
oder auf dem Blog.
Bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüssi!
Ihr könnt ja mal schreiben, was euer Lieblingsrezept
mit Erdbeere oder mit Rhabarber ist.
Schmeckt euch der Kuchen?
Gut.
[Musik]